à 2 12e circonscription des yvelines le
fn sera représentée par jean luc le gall
est déjà candidat aux élections
départementales de 2015 il se présente
cette année pour les législatives ancien
directeur financier il est retraité
depuis trois ans ça fait 35 ans qu'il
habite dans la circonscription le fn
souhaiterait représentait la principale
force d'opposition à la politique d'
emmanuel macron jean-luc galets insiste
sur l'enjeu national de cette élection
législative on écoute le mandat de
député est un mandat national même si
l'élection est local c'est un mandat
national
on doit s'occuper de problèmes nationaux
voter les lois ne pas aller voter
les amendes et faire des propositions
pour améliorer le système législatif
français qui a rencontré un grand nombre
de maires en tant que candidat front
national mais en aucun cas le rôle de
député sera de m'occuper d'affaires
uniquement local du